it may not look like much but this might
just be
a moon shot this chinese machine can
turn around a cover test in only 30
minutes
and the company's founder says it could
provide the capacity for a million tests
per day
in the uk within a month okay if boris
johnson called me and they said
yeah so i think hi boris and we are
ready to help uk
so i think we have the best technology
and we can definitely
i'm willing to help
the test itself is the same familiar one
it's what happens after that's new
very new the technology only got
approval at the end of july
sky news is the first foreign media to
visit the lab
more than half a million 30-minute tests
have already been carried out as part of
the validation process
during covered outbreaks in cities in
china this summer
and the machine is now being used at
hospitals airports and other
time-critical locations across the
country
for the point of care test like the
molecular uh
30 minutes test let's say if you go to a
hospital
and there is an emergency for the
patient let's say they want to go to the
icu or even do a
operation very very soon then you need
that
short period of time for to get the
community
negative results the other benefit is
that the test is simpler to operate
anyone can be trained in half an hour
that could take the strain of some of
the uk's testing capacity
countdown started so this is more than
10 minutes into the 30 before we expect
to get
a result it's a covert test in the time
it takes to watch an episode of
coronation street
and without a vaccine testing is crucial
and this means there are two
types slower less expensive mass testing
to chart the spread
of covert 19 in the population an
on-demand test like this
for time-specific critical situations
and with light speed testing moonshots
start to look
less unlikely a lot of people when this
operation moonshot was announced
10 million people per day being tested
said that's not technically
feasible uh in the uk do you agree with
that
it requires a lot of equipment though
yeah but it can be done yeah it can be
done
the problem is production capacity
coyote is currently making 500 per month
and aims to double that by the end of
the year but the technology is there
half an hour in the machine and my
results are ready
and delivered a few minutes later
straight to my phone
two machines are being validated in the
uk right now the only country outside of
china
moonshots rely on much more than
technology though
logistics and cost are just as important
but in china at least they have a rocket
ready
tom cheshire sky news beijing